[Music]
ok so I am going to start by giving some
of the combinatorial aspects of absurd
randomness so what I'm gonna talk about
in this talk is basically what graph
theorists are washing combinatorial
extremely common enjoyed us think of
when they think of pseudo randomness so
within graphs there are sort of three
different regimes that people tend to
think about and they tend to have quite
different methods the first which has
been studied for for a long time is the
case we were talking about banded degree
expanders and so there's a lot to say
here I actually will not touch upon upon
this here
I imagine maybe somebody else is
touching upon it but I'm not going to
talk about it too much here what I'm
gonna focus on is firstly the dense case
where we're talking about graphs which
for which the the degree is basically
linear in the number of vertices so you
can think of it as being like the
average degree is n over 2 or the the
sort of edge probability or edge density
is 1/2 and the other case that I'll talk
about after that is what happens in the
sort of intermediate range between that
so when we're talking about a graph that
is density 1 over root n or or
thereabouts um okay so so that's that's
the intention and so to begin with this
this dense case the the sort of key
definition in this dense case of what it
might mean for a graph or in this case a
sequence of graphs to be quasi random is
if it satisfies a nice discrepancy
conditioner so the discrepancy condition
here is that we want to say that between
any two fairly large subsets of vertices
x and y the density of edges between
them is close to to P so we say that a
graph is p quasi random if if this
happens I should say here that actually
this this P I put in here is
kind of unnecessary but it's I'll keep
it there for future purposes okay so the
motivation behind this definition or
where this definition comes from is that
it's intimately connected to what's
known as a simmer eighties regularity
lemma and now this is basically just an
advertisement because Jacobs going to
talk about some rate ease regularity
lemma tomorrow I think so but basically
within the regularity lemma you can say
that any graph can be partitioned into a
selection of blocks such that most of
those blocks satisfy a condition like
this so you can partition into pieces
that satisfy this this quasi randomness
condition with some some fixed density
between between each pair and this is
very useful for us a lot of the time it
helps us embed graphs we don't look
within other graphs because we have this
this extra condition okay so in order to
state the sort of the main sort of
foundational theorem of what happens in
the dense case I'll just define the
adjacency matrix of the graph probably
everybody knows but so if you have a
graph on vertex set one up to n then the
adjacency matrix is just what you get so
the entry UV will be 0 if there's no
edge between U and V and would be 1 if
there is an edge between between U and V
so so this is a very simple example of
that and the thing we'll be interested
in is not reading the adjacency matrix
itself but the collection of eigenvalues
of the adjacency matrix so usually we
can say if you think so for example if
the graph is d regular then the the
largest eigenvalue this lambda 1.is is
always d and actually if it's bipartite
then the the least eigenvalue is always
minus t and then everything else is sort
of between that so the theorem i wanted
to get to says that basically there are
a bunch of equivalent definitions of
what it means for a sequence of dense
graphs to be to be quasi random a random
like so this is a very sensible
definition saying that you have
consistency in densities so if you if
you say shrink the saw
of the sets you're looking at then you
have the same density essentially
between all fairly large sets and this
this is equivalent you're just saying
that every large set has density P
inside there's just some simple
inclusion exclusion that shows there but
it's also equivalent to saying that if
you look at the adjacency matrix and
look at the eigenvalues of the adjacency
matrix it's equivalent to saying that
the the largest eigen value is is pn and
that's sort of saying that your your
regular up to some some smaller so most
vertices have degree P N and everything
else is much smaller than that so so
somehow just saying that the all the
non-trivial eigenvalues are are small is
actually enough to apply imply this this
discrepancy condition here another
sensible condition or another sensible
definition for what it might mean for a
sequence of dense graphs to be
pseudo-random is to say well maybe we
can say that for all fixed small graphs
this big graph contains the sort of
correct number of copies of that so
that's all this all this number is
saying this is the number that you'd
expect to get in a random graph and this
is saying that the graph should contain
should contain this number and it turns
out that this is also equivalent to to
this discrepancy condition and finally
it turns out that actually that's
implied we're just saying that the
number of copies of C 4 is is what you'd
expect are close to what Jacob and so
this theorem was originally proved by
John Graham and Wilson Cheung and Graham
were both here and there are some
earlier antecedent of this in the work
of Thomason and maybe Alan as well but
but we're saying what we're really
saying here is that we have a pile of
different definitions of what it might
mean for a graph to be quasi random and
it turns out that asymptotically
all of these things are equal so these
little or two depend on each other in
somewhere alright so for a future
reference I might
well firstly I can delete the third one
because it was sort of unnecessary
knowing the number of copies of c4 is
obviously a weaker condition than
knowing the number of copies of all
small drums and I'm gonna rename these
because if I want to refer back to them
referring to them as one two and three
is not exactly the best thing to do so
the first one I'll just called disks for
discrepancy the second one I'll call egg
for dragon values in the third one psych
for de cycle camps and I want to give
you some flavor of how you you prove
each of these things and so so for
example the the first one so going from
the eigenvalue condition to the
discrepancy condition relies upon what's
known as the expander mixing lemma again
this has various antecedent to the
literature but I think the first place
that this occurred in essentially this
form is a taper of a Don and shown from
maybe 1989 I've stated a little bit
imprecisely really this this works when
your your regular rather than when
you're away from regulars an extra
little term involved but essentially
it's saying the kind of thing that we
were looking for so it's saying that if
you have two large sets x and y the
density the number of edges between x
and y is this this P times the size of x
and y up to some smaller so in
particular if we know that these
eigenvalues are little o of P N and we
stick this in we're going to get little
OPN here and each of these have size at
most n so we get a little o pn squared
which is exactly what we were looking
for in fact this gives a slightly
stronger condition and when x and y are
smaller it gives something something
slightly stronger actually this this
particular lemma works all the way down
it actually works all the way down to
expanders it's not particularly
dependent upon whether or not it's a
dense graph or not that's something I'll
return to in a few minutes and the next
one I want you to show so I'm going to
just do it in a cycle so if you want to
show that the knowing the count of
cycles of length four implies the
eigenvalues then
the way you can do it is well if you
know the number of cycles of length four
is close to what you'd expect then the
same is true for circuits so instead of
you're allowing degeneracy so just paths
of length four that come back to
themselves possibly self-intersecting
when you're dense they're going to be
dominated by the actual cycles of length
four and okay but the number of circuits
of length four if you take the adjacency
matrix and you take the fourth power of
it then each of the the diagonal terms
is just going to count the number of
cycles from that vertex back around to
itself so so the number of circuits of
like four is actually just the trace of
this thing but also that's just the sum
of the fourth power of the eigenvalues
and and and then you're basically done
because assam because you know that the
largest eigenvalue was essentially PN
which means that that dominates the
whole sum and everything else has to be
much much smaller and the last the last
one I wanted to mention so the the last
thing that completes the proof of this
if you want to show that this
discrepancy condition implies this cycle
condition and so this actually follows
from a more general theorem knowing is
the counting lemma which is an essential
ingredient in applications of the
regularity lemma which says that if you
have a setup like this if you have a
quasi random graph then you can count
any any small graph and I'm going to try
and prove that so the the H equals C for
case is what we need but I'm actually
just going to try and give a short proof
for triangles so in the triangle case
you have so I'm going to rewrite things
so that the number of edges between s
and 2 is just written in terms of some
indicator function so this I of G is
just the indicator function for edges in
G and then the number of edges between s
and T is just counting over all s and s
and all T and T of this this indicator
function
and so with that notation the the
assumption that we have this assumption
about discrepancy saying that the number
of edges between s and T is close to to
P times s T can be rewritten in these
these second terms so I've sort of
deleted at this s T and now it's just
some sum over over a function M right so
the key here one of the keys here is
that this can be can be generalized to
generic functions so instead of so what
we have here is like the sum over all SN
T of this times the indicator of s times
the indicator of T but you can actually
generalize this to any zero one valued
functions UX and V Y so so this implies
this and the reason for that is that
this whole function is essentially just
linear in the value of U of X and
because it's linear in U of X that means
that the the optimum or the maximum is
going to be when it's 0 or 1 valued so
and that's the particular case where
you're actually dealing with an
indicator function instead of a
continuous zero one valued function so
you get this basically for free it's a
sort of continuous relaxation of the
previous
okay so assuming this what we want to do
now the aim is to try and count the
number of triangles so the cap for the
number of triangles if you ignore the
second thing I have here is basically
just this this first expression so this
is just counting over all XYZ of whether
XY is there Y Zed is there and ZX is
there and I want to show that that's
flows 2p cubed times s cubed and the way
to do this is to sort of telescope it so
righty-o - so splinter - into three
parts like this and then each of these
basically has the form that I talked
about on the previous page so so
actually taking the first one here sum
over X Y Z in s of IG XY minus P times
IG y ZD x IG ZX so really what you
should be thinking of here is forgetting
about the Z term so if you forget about
this z term then this just becomes a
function of Y and this just becomes a
function of X and then that's your uy
that's your V of X and it is exactly the
form that we talked about on the
previous page so so this whole thing is
just a little o N squared so if that
little o N squared introducing this Z
back in means that this first term is
little o n cubed and the same is true of
these these other terms are the same
they're actually just slightly simpler
than that than the first term okay and
so basically what I've just said there
is what's what's written here as well so
so you get this for free once you once
you have this this continuous relaxation
there are other more hands-on ways to
prove this this capting lemma but this
is sort of analytically this is sort of
the correct way to do it and it
generalizes more easily
all right okay so I want you to point to
some other things within this area and
actually some some open problems that I
think
interesting so so one of the things that
we've already mentioned is that to get
these equivalent definitions of cause
your atom Nisour what it means to be
random like it's enough to know that the
density of the graph is around P and the
number of copies of cycles of length
four is around P to the four times n to
the fourth so just density plus C four
camps gives you this P quasi randomness
you can ask when is it the case that you
get this P quasi randomness with a
different graph H so instead of taking
the density P and the number of copies
being what expect for C for you can you
can substitute a different age and then
you can ask again when is it the case
that that implies P quasi random so the
example we've seen is C 4 but
practically the same argument and again
this is in the paper of Chun ground
Wilson shows that cycles of even lengths
always working and there was another
result of it later by skulkin and Thelma
showing that complete bipartite graphs
work as well and there are also some
fairly easy negative results so one is
that you can't be forcing if you're not
bipartite and the reason for that is so
let's take
take a graph like this so I'm gonna take
four sets each of size and over for here
I'm gonna put a complete graph here I
put a complete graph and here I put a
complete bipartite graph and then
between these two I'm going to put a
random graph of density 1/2 okay so
complete in there complete between and
then all of these edges between our
random with density 1/2 then this has
density 1/2 so the density is 1/2 the
number of cycles of length 3 or
triangles is essentially n cubed divided
by 2 cubed which is what you'd expect in
a random graph but this is definitely
not what you'd expect a random graph to
look like there's massive empty blotches
and you know massive empty bipartite
graphs so so this is an example where
you have the right number of copies of K
3 the right density but it is definitely
not not cause your handle the other
thing that you can't expect to be
forcing is a tree because you get the
right number of copies of a tree if
you're just regular so if your graph is
regular then you can just build a tree
in whatever way you want you don't need
to have any quasi randomness to that but
the counterpoint to this is there's a
conjecture which says that maybe the
condition is is just get rid of those
two things and say well if you're
bipartite and you contain a cycle does
that mean that you're that you're
forcing and so to some extent so this is
known for some graphs but it actually is
still very very much open and and the
progress on it is tied to another
conjectural extremal graph theory which
I won't go into now am known as
sidorenko's conjecture and there's been
a lot of recent progress on that but
even so it's still very far from from
proving this original conjecture so just
to give a simple example
there's a result of myself and Jacob Fox
and Benny Sudha cough showing that if
you were bipartite graph where you have
one vertex complete to the other side
then it satisfies sidorenko's conjecture
and subsequently there was a result of
Sega D and Lee showing that actually it
also satisfies the forcing conjecture in
that case M but there are now a lot of
generalizations of this but this is in
some sense the easiest to to digest
um I should say and I think a lot of
people would agree with me that I don't
actually believe the forcing conjecture
is true I don't believe that sidorenko's
conjecture is true so but it's still
worth a go and we actually have a
stronger conjecture in the forcing
conjecture which definitely isn't true
okay so the next thing I wanted to talk
about is another result which can be
sort of added to this list so the thing
that I said here
this example shows that triangles can't
be forcing there they're bad for this
forcing property but what you can do is
you can strengthen the property and you
can say well ok instead of asking that
we have the right number of triangles
let's ask that we have the right number
of triangles but it's it's hereditary in
some sense so actually we have the right
number of triangles on every large
subset so so that's what what this
condition is saying is just saying that
actually in every large subset we get
that the number of triangles is right
and it turns out that that condition and
this is a theorem of sure motivation
shows that condition is equivalent to
all these others and implies all of
these others so so the theorem just says
and I I've stated it quantitatively
which is different to how I stated the
other ones M it says that if you fix P
and you take an epsilon greater than not
then there exists Delta greater than not
such that if you know this triangle camp
is consistent up to some Delta then also
this edge camp is consistent up to to
some epsilon so the original proof of
this theorem actually used
the regularity number and again Jacob
will talk a little bit about this
tomorrow the the regularity lemma is
very bad if you want to do anything
quantitative um and we're very concerned
in extremely combinatorics with doing
quantitative stuff so if you end up with
a band that looks like this a tower of
twos of hype and dependent on something
that's that's pretty bad so what we
realized is that actually you can find a
different proof which gives the deltas
linear and Epsilon and we also we have a
we have a more general theorem than this
in fact the shamone vishesh theorem also
has a more general thing saying that you
can replace triangles by any other fixed
graph and then the analogous theorem
holds and we were able to show that
actually if you're at fleek then the
dependency is linear and if you're any
other graph the dependency is polynomial
but there's still an interesting
question here about how you shift from
polynomial down to linear in the general
case and I should also say this um
another regularity free proof of this
was given by Christian ryr and Matias
shaft but they're proof gives worse
quantitative bands and errors and it's
sometimes it's actually slightly
different the result is slightly
different okay so one thing I wanted to
do before moving on to talking about the
intermediate case is I want to try and
justify why it is that we're concerned
with these kinds of quantitative shifts
between things so why do we care whether
we get this sort of tower of height
epsilon or this this linear band m and
in some sense the classical example of
this and from moving between quasi
randomness is is proving summer eighties
theorem but I'm not going to go into
that because presumably that's going to
be talked about in Julian Fernando's
course but I will mention something
which Luca also mentioned which is
Ramsey's theorem so so Ramsey's theorem
says that basically for any graph if you
take and large enough and you color the
edges of can and two colors there will
always be some monochromatic copies
and the smallest end for which that
works is the Ramsey number and we would
like to estimate these Ramsey numbers so
and the best bands that are known are
exponential on both sides but the
exponents differ so we have for the T
versus root 2 to the T and nobody knows
how to really improve this by any
serious amount so any improvement to
these by an exponential factor would be
a major result in combinatorics but I
think actually if you work this out
carefully the only improvement on this
since 1935 is multiplying it by two but
I'll talk about this so what Luca was
talking about was trying to come up with
um with constructive methods for for
equaling this the proof of this is
probabilistic what I'm going to be
interested in here is is this so T is
just the size of the graph here so I'll
just yeah yeah so can is the big one in
KT is the small one down here okay so
being a little bit more precise the the
upper bound for Ramsey numbers for many
years was this 4 to the T divided by by
square root of T and and this was
improved a little bit in the eighties
when Andrew Thomason got this down to 4
to the T divided by T instead of square
root T the result I'm just going to
mention very briefly is a super
polynomial improvement that you can make
on this but the reason I'm mentioning
this is because ideas from quasi
randomness and shifts between all of
these different notions of quasi
randomness are very important actually
proving this so it's a very very vague
sketch of what's involved is you can
show that if you have a graph that's
this large so a complete graph with this
many vertices which is two colors and
doesn't contain a monochromatic copy of
KT then it has to be quasi random by
which I mean the coloring has to be
quasi round
the red color and the blue color are
both both quasi random looking it turns
out that the amount of quasi randomness
is enough using some of these
quantitative versions to show that you
get roughly the correct number of
monochromatic KP when P is around log T
over log log T and this is already a lie
but um but it's close to true and then
where I'm being really vague is that
this allows you to contradict another
property that the coloring has to have
you can show basically that it has to be
quasi random and it also has to be not
positive random and you can you can
tailor it so that they they contradict
one another um but this is essentially
why we're interested in the relations
between these things and actually
something very similar happens when
you're trying to prove prove Roth's
there and more semi IDs there but okay
so let me move on to two sparser graphs
so what happens in in sparser graphs so
one question you can ask is well does
this Sean Graham Wilson theorem hold
when you just drop a little bit so now
you're going to assume that your density
depends on n as this sequence of graphs
changes but now it's it's tending to
zero so one thing I already mentioned is
that the eigenvalue condition still
implies the discrepancy condition so
this this expander mixing lemma is still
good when the density drops but the
opposite direction doesn't hold it fails
so so the discrepancy condition is not
enough to imply the eigenvalue condition
and the reason for that and I guess you
can think of this D here as being
something some little ol then um so is
that if you take two connected
components like this each of these will
give you an eigen value of our size D
and if this is much bigger than this you
won't detect this when you're you're
doing discrepancy you'll sort of just
just lose that
okay so and this is sort of emblematic
of what happens when you you drop in
density so when you go below constant
and density this kind of things too has
to happen in fact there are examples
where you satisfy this discrepancy
condition but you contain no triangles
but I'll get to that in a second I want
to just very briefly mention that it is
possible to actually fix this particular
one the the one about M having
discrepancy but no triangles as much
harder to fix but this can be fixed and
there's actually various different ways
to do it one is a theorem of Billu and
lineal which is a converse to the
expander mixing lemma and it says
basically if you have the satisfy the
condition of the expander mixing lemma
then actually every eigenvalue is is
small it's close to what you'd expect up
to some logarithmic factor and this is
sharp as well you need that that extra
log factor a different thing that can be
done is actually well you can say if
you're if you're going to allow yourself
to adapt slightly so if you're going to
allow yourself to throw away some of the
vertices in your graph then you can you
can find a sub graph which is close to
everything which still satisfies this
this eigenvalue condition so see you can
basically it's saying that the example i
have on the previous page is kind of
close to the worst possible example
[Music]
so I wanted to mention one other thing
which is involved with with kata graphs
and there's a different kind of positive
results so again probably everybody
knows what a kata graph is but
essentially a kata graph is just a graph
that's defined by a group so your group
is your vertex set you take some subset
of that group and preferably symmetric
for Furi you can you can do without if
you're dealing with bipartite and kata
grass but for us let's assume that it's
equal to its inverse and you say that
the the kata graph is then what you get
by taking by connecting G to s times G
for for each s and there are several
examples of this actually one is
something I should have mentioned much
earlier so I've been talking about quasi
random graphs are there giving any
examples obviously random graphs are
quasi random graphs but the the sort of
standard example apart from random
graphs are the Paley graph where you
take ZP as your your group and then you
have density half within this because
you're connecting things if they differ
by a quadratic residue okay and it turns
out that this is this is a quasi random
graph it's actually very quasi random as
we'll we'll see in a minute I'll come
back to this example a couple of times
before the end of the talk so another
example of kata graphs is the the ram
anujan graphs of Liubov tsuki Phillips
and sarnax so these are actually in the
banded degree example where we have
something that is essentially optimally
has has optimal eigenvalues so the
eigenvalues are as as small as they can
be um okay so and as I'm sure people
know there's been some some great
breakthroughs recently on constructing
bounded degree expanders like this ram
anujan graphs by Marcus Spearman and
shrine estava
okay so but the result I want you to
mention here the first result I want you
to mention here is a result of cahaya
kerala shocked saying that actually if
you're dealing with a carry graph of an
abelian group then it turns out that
actually there's no problem here you can
actually take this
this discrepancy condition and you get
this eigenvalue condition back just just
automatically and I just wanted to
mention that actually this can be proved
for for an e group so it turns out that
you can generalize from an abelian group
to adding group using the Groff and
deacon equality and functional analysis
and okay but I just kind of want to
mention that in passing but basically
sometimes it is possible to save these
things this is for sparse cross this
this actually holds for any density
doesn't actually matter what the density
is so in some sense
what's saying here is that KD graphs are
symmetrical enough to bootstrap
themselves so you get from this weak
discrepancy condition to the eigen value
condition and that if you stick that
back into the expander mixing lemma you
get to replace this n by a square root X
Y so it's sort of somehow bootstraps
itself in some strange way and all right
so for the intermediate case one of the
natural definitions of pseudo randomness
and I think you fare we'll talk about
others on on Friday when he speaks is to
say that a graph is P better jumbled if
it satisfies this particular condition
so so this side is kind of what we
expect you're looking at the discrepancy
between X Y and P XY and this side maybe
looks a bit little ad hoc but the reason
for this is it's kind of what Luca was
saying arity the definition comes from
the theorems so so one thing that's
happening here is that random graphs
satisfy this condition so M so a random
graph will asymptotically almost surely
have this property where your beta is
something like square root of PN and
actually that that beta is essentially
best possible as well so you can't do
better than that
so either's there are results showing
that you can't have this this property
with anything anything better than that
the other thing is that it just comes
from from the expander mixing lever so
the expander mixing limit tells you
exactly this form that you get some
lambda x times square root X Y and in
that case the natural definition is what
we're talking about
nd lambda graphs so an ND lambda graph
is n vertices regular of degree D and
every eigenvalue except the largest is
less than or equal to lambda and in that
case it satisfies this condition which
is this p beta jumbled miss condition
with D over N + + lambda stuck in so so
this p value jumbled mess is is natural
once you see the expander mixing lemma
and you see the comparisons with with
random graphs yes I guess so so it's so
this is just measuring multiples of the
standard deviation from Himanshu
okay so I I wanted to give some some
examples of these so so one is a subject
that has received a lot of study in
algebraic graphs theory which are what
are called strongly regular graphs so
this is like an ND lambda graph except
we assume that every pair that are
connected has the same number of common
neighbors and which we denote by mu and
every pair that's not connected has
basically the same number of common
Abers which we call em so i got the
wrong way around called nu it always ito
and the result here is basically that if
this new indicia are new and each are
close to each other then actually this
is a strongly strongly regular graph
this nd lambda where this is close to
optimal so root D is basically as good
as you can expect to get for for this
lambda
so and from that you can get an example
of one of these these graphs so this
Paley graph actually works in this case
as well so it satisfies not only as it
caused you random but it actually
satisfies this there's much stronger
condition with essentially optimal
constants here so so again this
paragraph is where we have vertex set Z
Q one thing I didn't mention earlier is
that Q has to be congruent to 1 mod 4
for this symmetry condition and we join
them if their difference is a quadratic
residue and then you can check it's very
easy to check that this is this
satisfies this condition with
essentially two vertices basically Q
over two degree and essentially Q over
four common neighbors between NT 2 and e
2 vertices and the point being that
they're they're so close to each other
that it just gives you this this is a
very strong quasi randomness another
example which comes from finite
geometries and this happens quite often
that you get examples coming from finite
geometries and more generally coming
from KD graphs and other algebraic
conditions there there are good reasons
for this actually and maybe I'll mention
in a second so but the example I wanted
to mention is you just take projective T
space over F Q as your your vertex set
and basically what we're going to do is
we're going to form a graph by by
joining to two of the elements in that
set if there are thuggin all to one
another so if they're scalar product is
0 then then we join them like this and
then it turns out that this particular
graph is extremely highly souter on them
and the reason for that again is that
it's it's quite easy to analyze the the
linear algebra of this thing so I've
kind of written down what's happening
here but essentially you can work out
exactly that the square can be written
like this and then that very easily
gives you the eigenvalues and show
you get something like like square root
D so in fact this example I'll come back
to this example in one second so I
wanted to mention a second example due
to Naga Island which is really very
surprising and so at least to a
combinatorial s this seems like a very
surprising thing so there are triangle
free graphs which are optimally
pseudo-random so that's what this is
saying
but with density n to the minus
one-third so so actually the degree is n
to the 2/3 and let me say a little bit
about this here so
so this thing has density and to the
minus one-third whereas and there are
various ways to try and produce triangle
free graphs using random graphs so it's
obviously the most natural way to
produce graphs satisfying this kind of
condition is using random graphs so one
thing you can do is take the random
graph GNP so this is where every edge
and an end vertex graph is chosen
independently with probability P if you
do this then you'll get loads of
triangles so you'll get P cubed times n
cubed triangles so it looks like the
only way you're going to guarantee that
there's no triangles is if you have this
less than 1 which means that you should
take P to be to be 1 over N and that's
much sparser than this okay but old sort
of not lost here you can actually make
do some modifications that do better
than this so one thing you can do is you
can draw your random graph and then for
each triangle you can just try and take
one edge every each triangle okay so
what are we doing we're taking the total
number of edges as this if for each edge
we're removing a triangle and then the
total number of edges that we're
removing provided it's smaller than this
we still get a fairly big dense triangle
free random like graph and in that case
we want P to be less than something like
like 1 over root n but this this 1 over
root n that we get from modifier
modifying random graph is still
significantly smaller than this and you
can actually run much much more
complicated processes using random
graphs so and to something called a
triangle free process and if you run the
triangle free process you still don't
get very much above 1 over root n you
get maybe an extra log factor or an
extra root log n factor and so basically
the point here is that this thing
shouldn't exist
yes gives them two minus 1/2 so that's
if you compare these that's P squared
time alright so um okay but this this is
extremely surprising and part of the
reason I wanted to point to this is
actually we don't really know equally
good constructions for other graphs
there are a few exceptions to this so
actually this generalizes franny odd
cycle we know things that are basically
optimal but we don't know how to
construct K for free graphs which are
are optimally pseudo-random in this
sense and it's a very interesting open
problem to try and construct these
things in fact the best that's known for
K free or for free graphs is the the
previous example I mentioned coming from
these these projective t planes and
there are various reasons why we'd like
to know this it actually turns out that
this example is extremal for quite a lot
of questions in an extremal
combinatorics i'll I'll mention one at
the end but am okay so but first let me
mention just a few sort of properties
that that these a few simple properties
that these kinds of graphs have so one
is is this so the independence number of
a Pho jumbled graph is less than or
equal to beta divided by P from the
proof of this is very simple where you
just stick it into the condition the
number of edges within you is just given
by so this expression here which we know
is less than beta u number of edges in
here is zero so this is P u squared and
that implies exactly this this original
band now the funny thing about this is
let's actually stick in some
some think of this as an ND lambda graph
so let's take beta to be equal to lambda
and our lambda here let's take it to be
basically optimal so so it has
pseudo-random as it can be and let's
take our p to be d divided by n which is
is what it is in an ND lambda graph then
this tells us that alpha g is less than
or equal to n divided by square root of
d now if you know anything about random
graphs you know that this is actually a
really bad band and this is it looks
like a terrible bound for for a random
like graph to have because if you take G
n D so D regular random graph with n
vertices then the the independence
number of this should be something like
n over D maybe times some some log
factor so this is really quite a long
long way off from this okay but it turns
out that actually again this is optimal
so so there are strange examples of and
this one's not as strangers as no this
one with slightly strange examples that
to give this kind of thing and the
example is let's take a paragraph but
instead of taking the Paley graph for a
prime let's take the Paley graph for a
prime squared if you take the pantograph
for a prime squared it turns out that
actually the original subfield GFP is is
old quadratic residues the entire thing
is quadratic residues and the reason
it's all quadratic residues is well GFP
squared is just defined as the splitting
field of all quadratic polynomials over
GFP so actually x squared minus a always
splits which means that there's always a
square root in this extended field for
for a so so it's all quadratic residues
so now you want to find an independent
set so you want everything to be
connected by a quadratic non residue
instead of a quadratic residue
but then we know the residues times
residues or residues and residues times
non residues are non residues M so all
you do is take a non residue and
multiply by that and then your you get
your your large independent set and
actually this has exactly the right size
that comes out of this so even though it
feels like this thing shouldn't exist is
it again does M and actually this this
also transfers over to if you look at
chromatic number so so for the case of
chromatic number the exact same thing
happens so um so for chromatic number
you can take this previous band so this
sin alpha G is less than or equal to
beta over P and well the chromatic
number is also always bigger than n
divided by the independence number and
so that just just gives this so that was
coming from and again this is sharp so
if you use the example I gave on the
previous page this is this pantograph
then it again shows that that this is a
type thing yeah it's so the final
property I wanted to mention which is a
fairly important one is about camping so
how well can you do if you try and count
small subgraphs within this thing and
here the condition is that if your P
beta jumbled and your beta is is this
small so this this looks fairly
arbitrary but it seems to be tight I'm
strangely M then the number of label
copies of H and G is equal to two this
so and again for triangles this is tight
so actually if you take Allan's example
what's happening here is that as your
density comes up so let's suppose you
stay at a point where you're optimally
pseudo-random here as pseudo-random as
you can be and you're raising the
density then up to the density of n to
the minus one-third you can find
optimally pseudo-random triangle free
graphs once you pass that point as soon
as you go above this and
- a third you get exactly the same
number of copies as you get in in a
random graph see really of some sort of
sharp threshold behavior happening
within pseudo random graphs where you go
from no copies of triangles to basically
as many as you get in a random graph and
again we think that probably probably
four clicks this is Teich or close to
touch but we have no construction that
comes anywhere near this and this is
important for us because and again this
will be mentioned to some degree by ufa
on on Friday we have some results
showing that you can take classical
combinatorial theorems and like Ramsey's
theorem or to Ron's theorem and transfer
them to to the sparse setting see you
can say that if you move to this bar
setting you get the same theorem holds
essentially so if you take a pseudo
random graph and you color the edges of
that pseudo random graph then you're
still guaranteed to contain
monochromatic triangles and the extent
to which we can do that depends
basically on this theorem and variance
of this theorem so we'd like to know
that the places we've got to are sharp
so the particular example I just
mentioned which is Ramsey's theorem for
two colors we actually know the sharp
threshold we know that again an even
stranger property that below n to the
minus 1/3
you get no copies and once you go above
this n to the minus 1/3
you get Ramsey's theorem holds so you
can to color and you still get and
monochromatic copies of the triangle
okay and the final thing that I wanted
to mention which is again like at the
end of when I was talking about dense
graphs I want to give some sense of why
this is interesting or why why we look
at these things and so one thing for
which this is essentially optimal is
you're interesting the question of max
cuts so suppose you have an M edge graph
then what is the max cut of that so you
want to find two sets and then you want
to estimate the number of edges between
that you want to maximize maximize so
it's very easy to find a coach that has
m over two edges between us you can
basically do it randomly or you can
do some you can just do some swaps so so
split it as you want and then just put
each vertex into the side that's best
and so that gives em for two and it's
always possible to do a little bit
better than that so you can always find
a cut that has M over two plus some
multiple of root n edges and some more
precise results are known in that bush
so that's always the case and but
there's a result of no gallon from 96
showing that if you also know that the
graph is triangle free then you can you
can do significantly better than that
you can say that the max code is at
least M over 2 plus Omega M to the 4/5
yeah this is a very natural question um
it doesn't really look at least to me at
first pull out the first blush it
doesn't really look like it has anything
to do with with pseudo random graphs but
actually the extremal example in this
case is is allen's example that i've
mentioned so it turns out that basically
the best you can do is this thing and it
gives exactly exactly this kind of bad
the reason for that is something I
haven't mentioned which is that if you
have an N D lambda graph then the max
code can be estimated in terms of of the
eigen values the smallest eigen value
and then that that easily gives this and
but this is an example where the
question I mentioned earlier of trying
to construct optimally pseudo-random K
for free free graphs of maximal density
or high enough density is necessary if
you wanted to do the same question for K
for free graphs and we don't really know
what the answer is in that case and
there are other questions like this so
there's also work by by Jacob and
Chumlee and Benny pseudo curve on the
high ocean conjecture where a similar
things had thing happens actually it
really strongly seems to depend on on
constructions of pseudo random graphs
and there are several other examples ok
so I I will stop there
[Applause]
so this week all the pseudo-random
because they have some random properties
but like with expanders I think of
pseudo-random misses like you can take
random walks and actually generate you
get I mean you get the same expansion
property so with an expander where
you're thinking about just this expand
their property you get the same thing
here and from this it's it's basically a
stronger condition that it's really
these definitions are motivated by by
our obsession with bounding things or
with taking one structure and finding
another structure inside it and this
seems to be the thing that that really
drives this but it wouldn't surprise me
actually I've thought about this a few
times if stronger notions of pseudo
random or different notions of pseudo
randomness could be used for example to
improve the bound on Ramsey's theorem
further it may be that the other notions
from from computer science or other
notions that people here have been
studying would be helpful in that
context tight I simply don't know
I'm gonna guess what it's always called
pseudorandomness or are we calling it
because so well it's random like right
so there's there's only a couple of
things you can call random like one is
random like one is pseudo random another
it's quasi random it's funny within the
area it tends to be that this quasi a
random gets reserved for this dense case
with these equivalences at least in
practice that tends to be what's used
and pseudo random tends to be used for
these these sparse effects
there's Wallis vagueness because one
property implies another and it goes
both ways there's a strong sense of yeah
sorry I actually had a similar question
so I know that you know expanders
obviously then used for a lot of
constructions for and explicitly for
doing you know lower bounds and upper
bounds and so on so in some of the urals
you sort of had not a random graph you
have like a Cayley craft or whatever
right yeah yeah yeah so some of those
seem like they could be used in actual
constructions I just don't know if they
have a lot of this thing I mean so
algebraic constructions to some sense
have a sort of are generically pseudo
random in this sense because you can you
can so if you take an algebraic
construction over FP then you can use
the vague conjecture x' and things like
that to show that actually they're very
strongly pseudo-random so there's
actually a there's a whole host of
examples that you can you can use here
basically anything else or break and
generic should work but finding ones
that satisfy the extra properties you
want is really the the trickier
it's maybe worth mentioning you give
this example of a Paley graph of F Q or
Q was a prime squared which had a huge
independent set and we think that for
people for Q being a prime it probably
is actually much better than what we
know how to do that's yeah yeah so there
is so yeah what Jacob is saying is that
if you take this pantograph P Q where Q
is now actually a prime then you can ask
how big is the independence number here
and we kind of believe that most of the
time the independence number should be
something like log Q are close to log Q
there are proofs that infinitely often
it gets bigger than this so it gets up
to log Q times log log Q I think that's
conditional upon the Riemann hypothesis
but um you can get some log log log Q
definitely but most of the time it it
actually seems fairly likely that this
works so this would just give a
constructive example but of course
proving that's very difficult I think
the only thing that's actually known is
that the leak and independence number of
these are less than root Q so basically
what comes from this Hoffman bent and so
even though it should be something small
like this the best we know is what comes
out of this this Hoffman member this
this relates relates to some very
difficult and conjectures and I think
it's known to be root Q minus one it's
something ludicrous reading so not a
little oh no I think there's is root Q
and then there's possibly a paper by a
memory arooga who's a very clever number
of theorists who improves it maybe but
one in special cases as well
[Applause]